[Musica]
sul pianeta terra nel corso della storia
ci sono state cinque grandi estinzioni
di massa dovute principalmente a
cambiamenti climatici avvenuti per cause
naturali oggi noi siamo alle porte della
sesta grande estinzione di massa Anche
questa per colpa di un cambiamento
climatico Ma che che ne dicano i
negazionisti Stavolta non è colpa della
natura come in quelle precedenti ma è
colpa
nostra Infatti mai nel corso della
storia del nostro pianeta c'è stata c'è
stato un così rapido aumento delle
temperature globali come è avvenuto
negli ultimi due secoli dalla
rivoluzione industriale ad oggi ci sono
stati cambi cambiamenti di temperatura
nel corso della storia Sì assolutamente
così veloce no mai e a questo
negazionisti non sanno cosa rispondere
gli effetti del cambiamento climatico
Ormai sono sotto gli occhi di tutti
abbiamo estati sempre più calde abbiamo
effetti atmosferici sempre più
devastanti abbiamo bombe d'acqua
alternate a periodi di siccità abbiamo
scioglimento dei ghiacciai
acidificazione degli oceani perdita di
biodiversità ed estinzione Delle specie
e molto altro ancora
Ok ma secondo me la cosa più grave di
tutte queste in realtà è solo una ovvero
che molti di noi non si rendono conto
che il problema del surriscaldamento
globale non è un problema lineare Ma è
un problema iperbolico Cosa vuol dire
Questo significa che anche se sembra
lontano nel tempo La devastazione
ambientale in realtà è dietro l'angolo
perché perché accel sempre di più e
perché c'è questa accelerazione Gli
scienziati l'hanno ben studiata ci sono
dei meccanismi che si chiamano
meccanismi di retrazione positiva o
retrazione climatica faccio un esempio
molto semplice i condizionatori L'estate
è sempre più calda ogni estate è più
calda di quella precedente Quindi le
persone utilizzano sempre di più i
condizionatori ma più utilizziamo i
condizionatori più emettiamo gas serra
Più emettiamo gas serra più aumentiamo
la temperatura del pianeta più aumenta
la temperatura del pianeta più le stati
diventano calde più le stati diventano
calde più utilizziamo i condizionatori
capite è una cosa esponenziale
iperbolica come una pallina su un piano
inclinato non mantiene la stessa
velocità ma accelera sempre di più
Ebbene quindi questo va ben compreso il
problema è alle porte ed accelera sempre
di più ma come incide effettivamente il
su riscaldamento globale nella nostra
vita di tutti i giorni faccio due esempi
di cose poco considerate dai media ma
secondo me estremamente
importanti c'è stato un momento nella
storia in cui la vita sul pianeta era
completamente assente nella fascia
centrale del pianeta cioè la vita era
soltanto nel nord e nel sud del pianeta
mentre al centro Nella zona equatoriale
non c'era traccia di vita Ebbene Questo
sta per risuccedere i popoli che che
vivono Sulle fasce equatoriali vicino
all'equatore
già soffrono La siccità ma ne
soffriranno sempre di più e la fascia di
Sec cità aumenterà le sue dimensioni
sempre di più e ora capite che questi
popoli che già adesso hanno problemi a
coltivare avere il cibo Se si troveranno
completamente privi di cibo e di acqua o
muoiono o se ne vanno giustamente Ecco
secondo l'ONU entro il
2050 ci sarà un miliardo di persone di
migranti climatici che si sposterà dai
Paesi equatoriali dai Paesi poveri ai
paesi più ricchi un miliardo di
persone si sposteranno e questo
ovviamente cosa provocherà qui
provocherà conflitti sociali aumento
della povertà aumento della criminalità
e porterà a delle vere e proprie guerre
climatiche per accaparrarsi quelle poche
risorse che ci saranno per colpa del suo
riscaldamento globale avete capito bene
Ho parlato di guerre Ma c'è anche
qualcosa peggiore di questo il
fitoplancton i fitoplancton sono dei
microorganismi piccolissimi che vivono
nell'acqua e fungono da nutrimento per
un'infinità di specie marine ma hanno un
ruolo naturale ancora più importante di
questo ovvero creano oltre il 50% di
tutto l'ossigeno del pianeta Ebbene qui
il problema è che il surriscaldamento
globale sta scaldando il mare sempre di
più e sempre più velocemente e il
fitoplancton non riesce ad evolversi
altrettanto velocemente per resistere
alle nuove temperature dal
1950 ad oggi i livelli di fitoplancton
nel mare si sono ridotti del 40% Ecco vi
lascio soltanto immaginare le
conseguenze devastanti che ci sarebbero
se si estinguesse quel produttore Natur
di oltre il 50% dell'ossigeno del
pianeta le conseguenze sarebbero
irreparabili
assolutamente ok potrei andare avanti e
citare molti altri esempi orribili ma
non voglio far venire gli incubi a
nessuno stanotte quindi chiediamoci
Quale può essere una soluzione a tutto
questo premessa non c'è una soluzione
Cioè non ce n'è solo una ce ne sono
diverse ok Non possiamo puntare solo su
una cosa ma dobbiamo fare divers cose
spesso si parla di rendere più
ecosostenibile la produzione energetica
assolutamente
fondamentale Però è stato stimato che Se
volessimo
cambiare l'intero sistema produttivo da
quello tradizionale a quello eolico e
solare ci metteremo più di 20 anni
Ebbene non abbiamo 20 anni secondo la
Global Commission of Economy and climate
Noi abbiamo circa 10 anni di tempo prima
che questi meccanismi di retrazione
climatica si attivano attivino prima che
parti questa accelerazione dopo la quale
tutto quello che faremo sarà poco poco
efficace Quindi cosa possiamo fare
potremmo potremmo smettere di utilizzare
le auto eh Che ne
dite No non direi di no perché poi come
andiamo al lavoro come andiamo a fare la
spesa e tutto il resto potremmo
abolire il calcio Eh perché il calcio ma
non so se lo sapete ma una partita di
calcio notturna consuma quanto una
cittadina di 40.000 abitanti per 90
minuti di una partita si utilizza il
fabbisogno energetico di 12 famiglie per
un
anno ma no non possiamo abolire il
calcio no ci sarebbe la rivoluzione il
giorno dopo non come se i governanti
stessero completamente
ignorando ente Apocalisse
climatica Quindi cosa possiamo fare
potremmo abolire le crociere no le navi
da crociera in Europa
inquinano 20 volte di più di tutte le
auto dell'Unione Europea 20 volte di più
poi ci chiedono di fare le targhe
alterne no Come se servisse a qualcosa
va bene No vabbè non possiamo nemmeno
abolire le crociere allora cosa possiamo
fare per non incidere troppo sul nostro
stile di vita
potremmo diventare tutti vegani
eh Certo sarebbe una cosa straordinaria
perché purtroppo il consumo di prodotti
animali e di carne derivati è uno dei
principali responsabili del
surriscaldamento globale oltre il 15% di
tutte le emissioni gass Serra derivano
dalla produzione di prodotti animali
inoltre il metano che è largamente
prodotto da questo consumo nel breve
periodo è quasi un centinaio di volte
più distruttivo della CO2 Quindi se
tutti diventassimo vegani sarebbe un
aiuto straordinario per combattere il
surriscaldamento surriscaldamento
globale ma ovviamente no cioè non non
diventeremo tutti vegani E soprattutto
non diventeremo tutti vegani entro 10
anni quindi non può nemmeno essere
quella la
soluzione però in realtà potremmo in un
certo modo Cosa significa significa che
è nata da poco una nuova Branca
tecnologica che si chiama agricoltura
cellulare che permette di ricreare carne
latte uova pesce pelle Qualsiasi
prodotto organico a partire da delle
cellule prese con una biopsia da un
animale vivo una biopsia completamente
indolore e ricreare tutto questo però
con un impatto ambientale
straordinariamente inferiore sicuramente
qualcuno di voi avrà sentito parlare di
carne
che Lasciatemi dire è un dispregiativo
assolutamente stupido messo in giro
dalle lobby contrarie a questa
invenzione per spaventare le persone in
realtà la carne coltivata Questo è il
nome scientifico perché è coltura dei
tessuti la carne coltivata avrebbe un
impatto ecologico straordinariamente
inferiore per la stessa quantità di
carne Si si produrrebbe più oltre il 90%
di gas serra in meno si cons
consumerebbe Inoltre oltre il 90% di
acqua in meno e non solo Si
utilizzerebbe anche oltre il 90% di
suolo in meno e questo è molto
importante perché purtroppo il consumo
di carne derivati è una delle principali
cause della deforestazione del pianeta
Pensiamo ad esempio all'amazzonia dove
oltre il 90% della foresta amazzonica
che è stata abbattuta è stata abbattuta
per fare campi di mangimi degli animali
che ci mangiamo invece se noi pass
assimo a una produzione da quella
tradizionale a quella Con l'agricoltura
cellulare non solo fermeremmo la
deforestazione ma potremmo anche
invertir E potremmo Quindi riforestare
quei campi dei mangimi e riforestare è
molto importante per cambiare il
cambiamento per fermare il cambiamento
climatico perché L'albero è la migliore
tecnologia per rimuovere la CO2
dall'aria Ora io lo so potrei andare
avanti e dire tanti altri vantaggi
dell'Agricoltura cellulare della carne
coltivata però so quello che alcuni di
voi Stanno pensando ovvero Sì va bene
tutto bello però io non mangerò mai cibo
sintetico io non mangerò mai carne di
plastica in realtà la carne di plastica
la stiamo già mangiando Perché le
microplastiche Oggi sono ovunque sono
anche nella carne e nei derivati degli
allevamenti cosiddetti biologici perché
perché il mondo non è più quello di 100
anni fa il mondo Oggi è inquinato e va
accettato le microplastiche sono ovunque
e le microplastiche causano tumori
causano infertilità e causano tante
altre gravi malattie Ma nella carne
coltivata le microplastiche non ci sono
perché non servono quindi non ce le
mettono così come non ci sono gli
antibiotici gli ormoni parass CDI
pesticidi contaminazione fecale e molto
altro e il fatto che non ci siano gli
antibiotici è estremamente importante
perché purtroppo negli allevamenti
stiamo bombardando gli animali di
antibiotici e questo sta trasformando i
batteri in super batteri e gli
antibiotici stanno diventando inutili di
anno in anno l'antibiotico Resistenza
sta facendo sempre più morti e secondo
il secondo l'ONU entro il 2050
l'antibiotico Resistenza diventerà la
prima causa di morte nel mondo se non
facciamo subito qualcosa e la carne
coltivata potrebbe aiutarci in questo In
fondo è solo carne carne pura creata in
un ambiente completamente sterile da
uomini con il camice
bianco Io so che qualcuno di voi dirà Ok
Sembra veramente utopico ha tantissimi
vantaggi però a me queste queste cose mi
suonano come
fantascienza e
basta In realtà la carne coltivata ha
già superato diversi test di sicurezza
in diversi paesi del mondo dove è stata
approvata e già la consumano l'Italia
invece è l'unico paese al mondo che ha
deciso di proibir non si è ben capito su
quali motivazioni però qui noi l'abbiamo
proibita Ecco e questo non solo perché
la maggior parte della politica
Purtroppo è contro questa innovazione ma
anche la maggior parte dei media sembra
schierata contro questa innovazione ad
esempio io ho trovato su tantissimi
giornali anche tra i più importanti
italiani una notizia un titolo che
diceva oltre il 95% degli italiani non
mangerà mai la carne sintetica
ovviamente loro la chiamano carne
sintetica Va bene io sono andato a
vedere come hanno fatto questo studio e
vado a scoprire che è un sondaggio che
hanno fatto su 600 persone 600 persone
che dovrebbero rappresentare 60 milioni
di abitanti va bene ma non è questa la
cosa più più interessante quello che mi
ha colpito è che loro hanno preso le
persone che rispondevano al sondaggio
dicendo sì probabilmente Mangerei la
carne coltivata e le hanno messa nel No
cioè quel 5% di persone a favore sono
solo quelli che hanno risposto
sicuramente sì Mangerei la carne
coltivata mentre tutti quelli che hanno
risposto Probabilmente sì Mangerei la
carne coltivata sono diventati contrari
e così si è ottenuto quel 95% di
contrari anche con quelli in realtà che
probabilmente la mangerebbero Ecco
questa è solo una delle tante tecniche
che usano i media per
manipolarci e questo è è orribile ma
quello che mi fa pensare anche è che in
un contesto in cui la maggior parte
della politica è contro questa
innovazione e anche la maggior parte dei
media sembra contro questa innovazione
Chi è che c'è a favore Chi è che
combatte a fianco degli scienziati per
promuovere tecnologie come questa per
aiutarci a salvarci dal cambiamento
climatico potremmo pensare le
organizzazioni e gli influencer qu
animalisti
ambientalisti ma in realtà no mi duole
dirlo ma anche da da quelle parti non
abbiamo un grande supporto Infatti io
Insieme a altri attivisti abbiamo
portato in Europa una campagna chiamata
Andes slotter Age per chiedere al
Parlamento Europeo di valutare la
possibilità di spostare i sussidi dalla
produzione tradizionale con gli
allevamenti intensivi a una produzione
alternativa più etica più ecologica con
anche appunto l'agricoltura cellulare
abbiamo raccolto più di 860.000 firme ce
ne mancavano circa 140.000 per
raggiungere l'obiettivo e purtroppo
quando abbiamo chiesto aiuto alle varie
associazioni animaliste gli influencer
animalisti ambientalisti ci hanno chiuso
le porte in
faccia perché perché la carne coltivata
è un tema divisivo perché c'è tanta
ignoranza e quindi si preferisce non
perdere iscritti non perdere i
sostenitori e mantenere una posizione
più di di silenzio è un peccato perché
avremmo potuto vincere questa battaglia
però è comprensibile Ma quindi la
domanda finale con cui vi chiedo è in un
contesto in cui la maggior parte della
politica e la maggior parte dei media
sono contro un'invenzione così
importante che potrebbe aiutarci a
salvare il nostro futuro e a salvare la
vita di tutti noi in un contesto in cui
anche quelli da cui dovremmo aspettarci
di avere un supporto
non lo fanno lo fanno solo Timidamente
per paura di perdere sostenitori
iscritti chi c'è allora a combattere a
fianco degli scienziati per cercare di
salvarci per cercare di salvare il
futuro di tutti
noi ci siamo noi ci siamo solo
noi vedete purtroppo Hollywood ciè
abituato che per quanto le cose possono
andare male per quanto ci possa essere
L'invasione degli alieni l'attacco degli
zombie o la peggiore calamità naturale
Noi alla fine in qualche modo ce la
caviamo alla fine troviamo sempre una
soluzione e ci
Salviamo ma in realtà questo non è un
film Questa è la vita vera questa è la
realtà se noi pensiamo che che i
politici i media ci salveranno
stiamo
freschi purtroppo loro la maggior parte
di loro non tutti ma la maggior parte di
loro guarda solo a breve per
se non siamo noi i primi a informarci su
queste nuove tecnologie e a informare
gli altri e a combattere la
disinformazione dei media e a chiedere
ai governi di togliere questi stupidi
divieti e anzi di promuovere tutte le
tecnologie che possono aiutarci a
salvarci la vita dall'imminente
Apocalisse climatica se non lo faremo
noi non lo farà
nessuno voglio concludere con una frase
il mio intervento una frase di Winston
Churchill del
1931 Lui disse Verrà un giorno in cui
abbandoneremo la folle idea di crescere
un intero pollo per mangiarne soltanto
il petto e l'ala e faremo crescere
queste parti separatamente in un
macchinario apposito Ecco io vi chiedo
di lottare insieme a me e agli altri
attivisti affinché questa profezia
diventi realtà
Grazie
ah